vite les gars vous vous souvenez comment
c'était avant
tu veux dire quand on était dans la
boîte un nom avant notre naissance
l'usiné sucrière tout ça quoi
et moi je m'en souviens le menteur mais
non tu vas voir c'est une chouette
histoire il ya des effets spéciaux du
suspense on sera même des héros mais où
là on y est regarde des cachalots
apporte la can qui va être transformé en
sucre à l'usiné aux dents lusine la can
et charrier sur ce tapis roulant pour
fabriquer du sucre il faut préparer
cette can
on commence par la couper en petits
bouts dans le trou de cale
un appareil avec des dizaines de l'âne
qui tour t'inquiète pas la can ne sent
rien et c'est tant mieux parce que ce
n'est que le début
ensuite la can continue son chemin de
machines en machine sur le tapis roulant
ça c'est le reder la can il est broyé en
tout petits morceaux
elle passe entre d'énormes marteau qui
tourne et licra contre une partie fixe
l'anglais ian banon allait remets toi on
continue dis donc c'est encore loin non
on y est presque
oh et puis zut à temps c'est pas fini
fais attention accrue action
dudon elle fait drôlement mal ton
histoire je t'avais prévenu
nous sommes au séparateur magnétique
c'est un gros aimant qui sait retenir
tous les objets métalliques qui prennent
et pourrait endommager les machines de
la sucrerie
je retire ce que j'ai dit elle est super
bien ton histoire très drôle hein et
pourquoi l'image est floue attends je
remets mes lunettes dont j'en étais ou à
huy après il y a le moulin rouge où
c'est là où y récolter le jus ah oui ça
je connais c'est presque ça mais en
beaucoup plus grand
la can est pressé entre ces énormes
rouleaux pour en extraire le jus
le jus de canne va servir à faire le
sucre mais comme pour le jus d'orange
par exemple il reste des déchets c'est
la bagasse en la brûlant dans une
centrale thermique ont produit de
l'électricité qui permet d'alimenter des
maisons partout à la réunion
ensuite on retrouve le jus séparer de la
bagasse vous allez voir ce qu'ils rêvent
nouveau le jus brut est encore remplie
de minuscules fibre il faut donc le nez
dehors tu as plein de panache dans le
nez chez toi la tête de bagages je
disais donc il faut nettoyer le jus
alors on le fait couler dans une sorte
d'énorme passoire mais les petits
morceaux il passe à travers
alors pour les attraper c'est plus
compliqué mais comment on fait pour
commencer au fait monter la température
du jeu à 70 degrés celsius dans le
réchauffeur ensuite le jeu est envoyé
dans le show l'heure c'est une cuve où
l'on rajoute lâchant une poudre qui va
permettre d'attraper toutes les
particules puis se mélangent pas dans un
bac de décantation appelé aussi
clarificateur on rajoute quelques
molécules bien collante
elles vont s'agripper aux impuretés
rassemblés par la chaux et le tout est
transformé en boue mais alors tu
transformes du bon jeu en bon quoi honni
de la boue sucré mais non la boue c'est
les saletés collés ensemble qui
finissent au fond de la cuve le jus de
canne plus légers restent au dessus bien
trop près je préfère ça le jus caire
continue son chemin dans l' usine alors
que la boue va être transformés en
engrais on appelle ça légumes
le gîte l'air est très liquide car il
contient beaucoup d'eau
on le chauffe pour que l'eau s'évapore
comme ça on obtient un ep liquides
surnommée siro la cuy ouf
15 heures il faut encore chauffer le
ciron dans un appareil qui ressemble à
l'évaporateur c'est le cuiseur c'est lui
qui transforme le sirop de l'évaporateur
en sucre battre autant d'accord mais
comment ils font pour qu'on soit tous de
la même taille ah oui pour avoir des
cristaux de taille identique on ajoute
dans le cuiseur quelques grains de sucre
le sirop les recopie pour qu'ils aient
tous la même taille c'est la
cristallisation aussi magique mais tout
le jus ne se cristallise pas on se
retrouve donc avec un mélange de sucre
et de sirop appelé masque 8 pour les
séparer on va laisser quick sommes dans
une sorte d'énorme essoreuse à salade
c'est lassant prévu
dans la centrifugeuse le sirop se sépare
en deux parties d'un côté il ya la
menace elle va servir à la fabrication
du rhum dans une listed et lits
spécialisés mais aussi comme complément
alimentaire pour les vaches l'autre
tuyaux amène le sucre vers aimer et à la
vous et doux
et puis ton visage
non
pas mal pas mal mais au fait d'où elles
viennent nos couleurs ça c'est une
question de cuisson est de taille de
grains cela permet d'avoir des arômes
différents
tiens toi par exemple qu est celui qui
se rapproche le plus des arômes de la
can
j'en étais sûr et donc nous voilà avec
un kilo de cannes ont fait 22 morceaux
de sucre comme nom moi je suis surtout
content de ne pas avoir fini en bagarre
soudan le nez de sucre blond ouais
la prochaine fois je vous laisse écrasé
dans le thread